SHOT IN THE HEAD ARE EXPECTED TO
SURVIVE.
ONE IS A MOTHER OF A YOUNG CHILD
AND THE OTHER A 24-YEAR-OLD MAN.
THE OFFICERS WERE SITTING IN
THEIR CAR IN COMPTON WHEN A MAN
ATTEMPTED TO AASSASSINATE THEM.
THE SCUM IS STILL TO THE LOOSE.
WE HAVE CREATED A CLIMATE OF
HATE AND INTOLERANCE WHERE
HORRIBLE ATTACKS AGAINST THIS
GROUP ARE POSSIBLE.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE HUNTED BECAUSE
OF WHO THEY ARE.
A CLIMATE THAT FORESTS
OPPRESSION.
BUT THE VICTIMS ARE POLICE SO
YOU DON’T HEAR THAT EVEN IF IT’S
TRUE.
YOU GET AN EMBARRASSMENT OF
CRITICS FROM THE MED IAIA AND TH
PROTESTORS AT THE HOSPITAL.
CLASS ACT ALL AND BIDEN CALLING
FOR GUN CONTROL.
AFTER HIS CAMPAIGN CHAMPIONED
PAYING BAIL OF A COP KILLER,
MAYBE HE SHOULD SIT THIS ONE
OUT.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
DEMOCRATS BRAVELY SAYING,
DEMONIZING COPS LEADS NOWHERE
GOOD.
OR ANCHORS SAYING THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU REDEFINE
VIOLENCE AS PROTESTS.
YOU THROW A MOLATOV AND YOU
KILL.
MAYBE IT’S TIME TO END THIS.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR SOMEONE
POINT OUT THAT THIS RAMPANT
VIOLENCE AND THE SILENCE OF
LEADERS MADE THIS POSSIBLE.
MAYBE DEMONIZATION IS DEMONIC.
WE DON’T LIKE TO HEAR THAT.
BUT THAT HAPPENED TO COPS.
SO NEVER MIND.
THE NFL THAT WAS SOME GAME.
DID YOU KNEEL?
DAGAN, ON THE L.A. COUNT
SHERIFF’S TWITTERS ABOUT THE
PROTESTORS SHOUTING THEY WANTED
TO THE COPS TO DIE AND BLOCKED
THE ENTRANCE OF THE HOSPITAL.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A HOAX.
I STILL CANNOT BELIEVE IT.
I AM DENIAL.
BUT IT CAME FROM THE SHERIFF’S
OFFICE.
THERE WAS PRESS THERE.
>> IT LEAVES A LUMP IN MY THROAT
HEARING YOU SAY THAT.
I JUST KEPT THINKING OVER AND
OVER, HOW DID WE GET HERE AS
A NATION?
REMEMBER, IT’S PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHO WAS SUPPOSED TO GIVE RISE TO
THIS HORRIFIC DISTOPPIA IN THE
UNITED STATES.
INSTEAD IT’S THE LEFT-WING
ANTI-COP MOVEMENT.
IT DIDN’T START RECENTLY.
I WANT TO MENTION THESE TWO
OFFICERS WHO WERE EXECUTED HERE
IN NEW YORK CITY BY SOMEONE WHO
TOOK THEIR OWN LIFE.
THIS WAS BACK IN 2014.
AN OFFICER WAS STABBED IN THE
NECK.
>> AND THE OFFICERS IN DALLAS?
>> EXACTLY.
IT’S THE LACK OF PUSH BACK BY
THE LEFT.
I WILL USE A PHRASE I HAVE HEARD
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT SAY, SILENCE
IS ACCEPTING THE UNACCEPTABLE.
LAST YEAR IT WAS WATER THROWN AT
COPS.
THIS YEAR IT’S CEMENTS IN WATER
BOTTLES.
WHAT IS NEXT?
>> DANA, DO YOU THINK THAT THERE
IS A LINK BETWEEN THIS KIND OF
VIOLENT RHETORIC AND THE ACTUAL
VIOLENCE?
>> WELL, I HOPE WE FIND OUT SOME
SPECIFICS HERE.
THEY OFFERED A $100,000 REWARD
FOR INFORMATION LEADING TO THE
PERPETRATOR.
THIS MIGHT BE GANG WARFARE OR AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT ACTED ALONE.
DO YOU REALIZE, GREG, I NOTICED
THAT THERE IS NOT A WEEK THAT
HAS GONE BY IN THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS, 3 MONTHS YOU HAVE NOT
DONE A MONOLOGUE ON THIS AND YOU
ARE NOT REPEATING THE SAME STORY
OVER AND OVER.
THERE ARE NEW STORIES THAT HAVE
TO BE TACKLED EVERY WEEK.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND THE DEPRAVITY
OF SOMEBODY THAT WOULD JEER THE
VICTIMS AT A HOSPITAL.
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN HELP, BUT
THAT’S SOMETHING MUCH DEEPER.
>> YES.
>> IT GOES TO THE HEART.
>> JUAN, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, TO ME THIS IS
A DESPICABLE ACT THAT SHOULD BE
CONDEMNED BY ALL AND IT HAS
BEEN.
YOU HEAR PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN BOTH
QUICKLY SAID YOU CAN’T HAVE THIS
KIND OF BEHAVIOR HAD A CIVIL
SOCIETY.
IT’S UNACCEPTABLE AND WRONG.
THAT IS CLEAR.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP’S CAMPAIGN
TRIES TO EXPLOIT THESE EVENTS TO
UNDERMINE THE WHOLE NOTION OF
A RACIAL JUSTICE MOVEMENT.
OF A MOVEMENT TOWARDS POLICE
REFORM.
NOW YOU CAN’T SAY THAT.
THE REALITY IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT’S EFFORT AT THIS LAW
AND ORDER RHETORIC IS NOT PAYING
OFF.
THE POLLS ARE CLEAR.
WE HAVE A POLL OUT TODAY FROM
MONMOUTH THAT SAID 52% OF
AMERICANS THINK BIDEN WOULD BE
BETTER AT LAW AND ORDER THAN
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
61% SAID TRUMP MADE THE PROTESTS
MORE VIOLENT AND WORSE.
YOU DON’T HEAR PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAYING THE GUY IN KENOSHA WHO
KILLED PEOPLE HE WAS A BAD DAY
OR NEVER SAID ANYTHING ABOUT THE
BOY WHO SKILLED THE COURT GUARD
IN A FEDERAL BUILDING IN
OAKLAND.
IN LOS ANGELES IT’S HARD TO STOP
GIVING THE HORROR OF SHOOTING
THESE TWO POLICEMEN.
BUT IN CONTEXT, TWO WEEKS AGO
A YOUNG MAN,KINSEY, 29 WAS
STOPPED BY COPS.
DROPPED CLOTHES AND A GUN WAS IN
THE CLOTHES AND HE WAS SHOT TO
DEATH.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF ANGER
IN L.A. OVER THAT SHOOTING.
IT DOESN’T JUSTIFY WHAT JUST
TOOK PLACE.
THAT’S THE WHOLE STORY.
>> THAT’S WHOLE STORY.
SO THIS SHOOTING AT 5:53, IT
ONLY TOOK YOU NEW MINUTES TO
CONNECT IT TO TRUMP.
TRUMP IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ELEVATE
ELEVATING THE FURY OF THE
PROTESTS.
GOT IT.
JESSE?
>> JUAN SAID IT’S DONALD TRUMP
UNDERMINING THE CAUSE FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE.
NOT THE GUY THAT SHOT THE COPS
IN COLD BLOOD.
IT’S THE PRESIDENT FOR TALKING
ABOUT THE GUY THAT SHOT THE COPS
IN COLD BLOOD.
HE IS THE BAD GUY.
GOT IT, JUAN.
HERE’S THE THING.
THE PRESIDENT CAN’T FAN THE
FLAMES OF THIS VIOLENCE WHEN
IT’S THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT
OVER THE SUMMER SAID POLICE
DEPARTMENT ARE SYSTEMIC RACISM
AND HUNTING DOWN UNARMED BLACK
PEOPLE.
IT WAS THE SAME CLIMATE WHERE
THE GUY SYMPATHIZED WITH THE NEW
BLACK PANTHER PARTY IN DALLAS
AND SNIPED OFF POLICE OFFICERS
IN DALLAS.
WE HAVE SEEN FOOTAGE ALL SUMMER
OF DEMOCRATS THROWING WOKS AND
BOTTLES AT POLICE.
LIGHTING THEIR PRECINCTS ON FIRE
AND JOE BIDEN SAYS VIOLENCE OF
ALL KINDS NEEDS TO BE CONDEMNED.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN EVER ALL KINDS?
I GOT THE FEELING ALL SUMMER